bonsoir messieurs dames bonsoir florence
alban écoutez je suis ravi d'être là
pour remettre le prix du césar du
meilleur film étranger
elle se passe bien pardon excusez moi
comment on fait le même métier a tourné
sa honda france est là le spectacle il
est prêt cette charte
à bientôt l'olympia première tournée des
zénith à lésigny carrément bien bravo
ne t'en fais pas trop dans l'humour si
je peux te voilà non parce qu'après
toxines ont jeté grièvement
je pense aux ben oui je peux te lire
j'en témoigne enfin en plus c'est vrai
que moi je te trouve meilleur à l'écran
si je peux me permettre voilà je trouve
que au cinéma tu es vraiment imprègne
enfin que c'est vrai que plus je te vois
sur grand écran plus je trouve que tu
prend de l'épaisseur
ça c'est à cause de la cantoche alors le
cinéma comme vous savez n'a pas de
frontières car lorsqu'il s'agit des
motions nous parlons tous la même langue
magnifique pardon excusez moi je te re
met vraiment j'ai adoré enfin chu ou pas
je trouve que tu as une épaisseur
dramatique là d'un coup fathi tu vois
quand je te vois comme ça à débarrasser
de tous les gags et tout je trouve que
vraiment là ça te va bien quoi voilà ce
regard [ __ ] avec un regard profond
quoi tu serais bien on tragédie en drame
un quart regarde regarde la caméra voir
que faire redonne mois se regarde
le wave asie avec la réplique mais le
cinéma n'a pas de frontière à [ __ ] car
lorsqu'il choisit d'émotion nous parlons
la même langue
ta [ __ ] tu penses tu que tu ma vie
devant moi je les ai sentis la away mais
je te promets là j'ai une vision je suis
sorti de ma zone de confort ouais ouais
j'ai sauté peut-être raison il se croit
attends je suis un acteur dramatique ou
quoi elles vidées et paca mais pacaya
est à tous qui s'ouvre je veux dire tu
pourrais tout faire quoi gaver en plus
c'est qu'un tu imagines tu veux faire
des films d'action du tout était têtue
pourrait être the rock français le rock
c'est vrai ça il y aura ya pas ici non
non au tce bay chiasso roch voisine
y a pas en france non ouais mais j'aime
bien je relis je suis tu veux tu fasses
le rock
sony n'est qu'il va faire the rock des
neiges le nic perdre il a bien sûr
fastoche craint ni les morts ouais moi
j'ai l'impression que vraiment là je me
demande même si la france c'est pas trop
petit pour toi bats pas tu as raison ce
que je me sens ira l'étroit dans ce pays
vont se croiser je suis là coincée entre
l'alsace la bretagne puis c'est un peu
frisquette j'ai les couilles dans les
vosges toi y'a pas de grands noms mais
moi je te dis mon pote je dois y aller
la cua carrière internationale pour que
tu vas pas hollywood là ils ont tous
fait ben voilà ouais moi je suis là je
sais pas pourquoi je suis là je devrais
déjà être dans le train pour los angeles
mais non il est là et le gros con il a
été alors que font alors que je suis un
acteur américain
vraiment j'ai pas plus qu'on tient
longtemps vie
vie star wars avec alban evans et cette
classe franchement non mais ce chic à la
française ça s'exporterait bien quand je
me dis une fois qu'à hollywood tu
pourrais devenir je sais pas moi et j
ride un grand parfum
ouais c'est ça la route mais bien sûr
ouais on y est là où admin tu le portes
bien regard paco rabanne encore avec
alban ivanov et les patous lui il est
bien sûr la latence pas parce qu'on est
au complet pas de parfum alors bien sûr
mais évidemment après tu sais ce que tu
fais tu ce qu'il savait ce que tu meures
jeunes pour entrer dans la légende toi
comme patrick dewaere tu te plains il ya
35 ans et ça y est là tu es un mythe
ouais voilà j'en ai 36 et je suis encore
là j'aurais dû me [ __ ] en l'air
l'année dernière tu vois mais oui ouais
c'est pas pro tu as raison non mais
c'est pas grave en même temps tu te fais
un petit suscite médiatique ça marche
obama bien sûr j'ai pas j'avais annulé
sa tournée pour dépression par exemple j
qui m'a tuer est un bad buzz et la taca
rien [ __ ] de passe de l'un viendrait
way we love
mais là où on passait là où vous allez
les étoiles ou spa photo ap c'est bon
merci la écoute tu sais moi quand je
peux aider la jeune génération non
miscibles j'étais coincé dans mon bocsa
louis et toi tu m'as mis dans l'eau mais
moi tu sais quand je peux aider plutôt
vers ces petits bonhommes je t'en prie
tout de suite tu es gentil gars qui
allait mon bonbon à dieu a lieu pourquoi
on bouffe pas après la cérémonie le toit
c'est pas sûr qu il escompterait on
ouais je te préviens je porte pas son
bout faible